hi everyone my name is taika white easy
and this is the wired auto complete
interview
I Google myself all the time knowing me
intimately is still not enough I just
need to know more and Welcome To My
Nightmare
[Music]
how many languages does take away to see
spit
what else will it be how many languages
does tiger White City collect English
that's the that's the one I can speak
the best and not even that good a little
bit of German a little bit of Maori
how tiger why did he get though well
I'll tell you how dark away
just the way that everyone else gets
thought I went and did a meeting with
Marvel they were awesome they loved me I
loved them that now we get that movie
how did Tiger why does he become a
director I didn't start till I was quite
late you know there's all these other
directors who started being like eight
years old and they're gonna be a
filmmaker I was like 30.
before that I was a painter
let's paint pictures film was something
I hadn't tried so I wrote a short film I
was like I'll give this a go and uh that
short film got nominated for an Oscar
well who cares didn't win
he good how to contact Tiger Woods
[Music]
Mal Mo
oh my God I'm the laziest actor you'll
ever
come across I played Hitler didn't read
anything about him I just played
Blackbeard and in our flag means death
I went on Wikipedia I typed in
Blackbeard and there's too many words I
read the first part which is like he's
from Bristol and I looked at the
bristolian accent which is like Stephen
Merchant
and uh I thought napped you had so I
just did my own accent that's it that's
that's my range my range is me I don't
try and I'm successful so
who does tiger why does he play in Thor
Ragnarok Korg Korg the big guy made of
rocks again my accent this shouldn't be
allowed it's not just a voice guys all
right I was in a motion capture suit so
all of korg's movements
that's real acting who does tiger why
did he play in the Mandalorian
IG
88. or 11. I play a um a bounty hunter
Droid called IG 88 the [ __ ]
who does tiger why does he play in the
Mandalorian ig-11 of course and even
that Kurt even that's just my own exit
this is really revealing for me I don't
think I've actually worked a day in my
life who does tiger why did he look like
he looks like a slightly older probably
more matured and better looking version
of tiger YC in 2015. who's tiger waititi
ask my therapist that's what we're
trying to find out right now
what does tiger why did he do
I asked myself that every day what am I
doing what was take away the first movie
the first feature length movie is called
Eagle vs shark starring Jermaine Clement
and Lauren Taylor and that was way back
in 2000 and
five
what country is takeaway City I'm not a
country
a human being
dude
no one wants to know what country has
taken away is he from
I'm not even gonna answer that because
you should know from the Glorious
Kingdom of New Zealand
can you answer the other question just
before that oh [ __ ] what did Tiger why
did you get an Oscar for well he didn't
get an Oscar for a short film but he did
get an Oscar for his feature film JoJo
rabbit for writing adapting a book
literally just ripping off a book
tiger white is he sucks JoJo rabbit
iconic lines I wrote it and I don't
remember any of the lines I think I just
whenever I finish something I just block
I block it out okay JoJo uh that's what
she's trying to do is to she's trying to
drive a wedge between us we have to we
have to get rid of her ah she's like a
little see how fast she was she was like
a little Jewish Jesse Owens where does
tiger why did he get his shirt uh steal
most of my clothes I have a great
stylist they deliver clothes over and I
try them on and then I don't give them
all back does tiger why does he have
tattoos yes he does he's got this little
tattoo he's got these tattoos a giant
big tattoo on his leg these are the
regret tattoos down there
uh what's the one on your wrist on my
wrist this is uh in New Zealand what we
call uh marai what we would call a
farinui big house and that's the
community that your tribe will come to
and they're named after an ancestor and
this ancestors pararaki who started our
part of the tribe does Tiger waititi
have a Grammy he sure does they are just
giving those things away I got the
Grammy for the best soundtrack
for Georgia rabbit
would pretty much just getting a Grammy
for making a playlist this section is
called is tiger white is he is Taiko why
does he yes he is
nice
I am I'm very nice is tiger in Bridgeton
[ __ ] is that
I might be in it
I mean I'm so busy I don't know I mean
obviously I don't know the names of my
characters I don't know anything about
what I've done I'm probably in Bridgeton
yes I'm in Bridgeton
and I loved it it was great it was that
it's a period
T movie show TV show it's a show it's a
TV show set in England
in the 1918
1700s and everyone's good looking and
it's sort of it's like mash but in the
1700s this type of White City
a good director
I mean I basically made seven movies
that had all been hit
you do the math taika why did the Korg
voice oh these are requests oh
boys is that what they wanted they
wanted me to do the cool voice well I'm
not a performing monkey okay bro and
then just do things on command do I go
why does he Kate Blanchett Mimi what the
hell is this oh when I'm showing you
something on an iPad
and people are like when your wife gets
home and you're like look at what my
score was on Weddle okay yeah I've seen
it
it was actually it was exactly like that
on set I was like this is how it's gonna
be and I want you to do this and this
could look really cool because you're
going to have a giant wolf and a zombie
army she's like
I could have taken last year off
takeaway City love and thunder I have
been described as that I guess you're
wanting a trailer everyone wants a
trailer I want a trailer not getting a
trailer tiger wait is the favorite films
really start I like all my films I like
Back to the Future The Graduate
Star Wars if I can watch you see
tiger why is the paintings figurative
slightly kind of like a little
experimental it's painting with oils and
gouache
not acrylics type of White City fashion
how do I describe my fashion usually
it's wake up and whatever
it doesn't smell like [ __ ] I put on
there's the end of the cards that's what
people Google there's probably all my
mum who did those she's on the internet
all the time Googling me she's very
proud I suspect it's her asking all
these questions
[Music]